yeah but tony robbins is very very
different
tony robbins obviously yeah he's a
self-help guy you know he's
he wrote all those books on sales and
making yourself great you know
being a better nlp all that stuff but he
he also like going to a tony robbins
event
you're going there for the experience
it's like it's like going to the super
how are you
how are you i'm 33. okay you know how
old tony is
he's probably in his 60s right he just
celebrated 60. you know when he started
doing his first event
now he was 23 24 years old right what's
the point
go talk to somebody his age tony used to
put up events with 10 20 people
tony had to overcome that it took him
two decades that's what i'm trying to
tell you
um he started selling courses
oh yeah tony was selling uh uh and by
the way here's what
this is coming from a guy that's
attended his courses about his books
about everything that he has
about his stuff from way back in the
days but he struggled with that because
he was known back in the days as the
infomercial guy
middle of the night you'd be sitting
there watching tv and he says are you
sick and tired of being sick and tired
is your job not fulfilling your dreams
have you made promises to your wife
of taking her to that one destination in
italy or france so you've not made it
happen
it's time to you know all these kind of
messages and it was information oh my
gosh let me buy this 200
program let me buy this 200 program so
he went through that for a long time but
what
tony that gets credit for is tony
recreated himself multiple times
some of these guys are going to get a
lot of shots that's going to be taken at
them
they're going to have to figure out a
way to recreate themselves remember
rogan was a fear factor guy
and prior to that he was an actor and
prior to that he was a karate guy
okay and he was a good looking guy that
was coming up then all of a sudden he
said
let me team up with dana white they
worked out together he started doing his
time still today he considers himself a
comedian
all the other stuff is secondary right
so comedy
ufc podcast he's recreating himself
i don't know how many times so the race
when people bring up names to me
the race of content is going to be who
can recreate themselves
the most times and stay relevant for
decades the reason why
ray charles and stink get the kind of
credit and respect that they get i
believe they're the only two
that have number one hits in four
different decades
four different decades think about how
much music changes every decade imagine
staying relevant
for four different decades it's a very
difficult thing to do to stay relevant
for different
decades you know so a lot of these
online guys they're gonna have to
overcome these you know who they are
you know all these videos that you do on
these guys that this guy does on them
yeah yeah but we're going to overcome it
some of them are not going to overcome
it but they're going to have to overcome
this phase of people like this going
after them saying how you make your
money's courses
right yeah it'd be interesting to see
what tony robbins would do if he was uh
younger and starting out in this day and
age how he would do it
i think he'd be 10 times bigger do you
think that i mean but do you think that
he
he baited his audience into thinking he
was some like big successful guy
when he first started like look at me
i'm rich when he first started doing
those courses
no i think tony's approach tony's
approach was
the story that makes tony very
vulnerable is when he was at his venice
apartment and his friend comes in he's
38 pounds overweight
he's disappointed he's hit rock bottom i
think he was working at jim rohn and i
don't know whether he was working in the
nutritional company with jim rohn
and he came from a place uh look i
screwed up my life then i went and read
books and then i changed my life
and i'm sharing what worked with me for
to you
so that's still a very noble way of
bringing the messaging he's packaging it
very well so it's
he's not coming from a place of let me
tell you how powerful i am those are the
people that sometimes get
uh a lot of people that come after them
for the right reasons now if they can
handle it
they're gonna be fine if they cannot
handle it they may need to want to
change their positions for example for
trump
trump enjoys people going after him his
entire life
that's his comfort zone it's not for
everybody
some people get rattled some people
don't like that he
loves it matter of fact he will
intentionally file a bankruptcy on a
business just to get you to write about
it
he is a very different kind of guy but
if somebody says
i want to be like trump when i grow up
you can't because you got to have that
guy's dna
if you don't have that guy's dna you
can't be like him you got to take a
completely different
uh uh play of a different person's
playbook rather than hits it's not going
to work for that personality
but if somebody online has trump's
personality they're going to be all
right
it's amazing how many people you can get
to follow you
and to worship you if you project this
this
wealthy persona you know what i mean if
you could put a ferrari in the
background of your videos
you can get so many people to follow you
not forever though
it's such a weird thing it's really
insane like how effective that is for
some people
yeah it's not forever though think about
it like you know like kardashian
uh they would say oh she's famous
because of that video
right i've been probably even guilty of
saying that you know she's famous
because that one video she did with
brandy's brother right
the porno yeah yeah with uh yeah
porn video that went out and everyone
said oh my gosh who's this girl and
she was friends with uh paris hilton and
all this stuff right okay
no problem you look at kim kardashian
today
how many times has she recreated herself
i mean they're on the 20th season of
keeping up with kardash i've never
watched an episode not
one time have i watched keeping up with
kardashians
you know how many people in my office
keep up with it and you sit there and
you say
at this point kim kardashian at this
point has reached saint status you know
what sen
saint status is here's what same status
it's not she's a saint
that's not what saint status is saint
status is no matter what you say today
no one cares today you can say whatever
you want about kim today
no one cares today she's reached a
tipping point
she's gonna the only thing she can do is
if she does something
royally stupid criminal
something you know it's completely out
of line
but she's reached a level right now that
she's got millions of haters
and she's totally comfortable with it
she still looks good
at 40. i don't know how old she's i'm
gonna assume she's 38 40. i don't know
her exact age
but i'm gonna assume she's gonna be that
age kim kardashian how old are you let's
see here
she's getting up there for sure she's 40
years old we're three days apart okay
cool i didn't know that she's october
21st so
she's three days apart in age i had no
idea where we're
i'm 78 she's 80. so we're we're uh
but you look at her good for you she
looks amazing
so now somebody could have said to her
at 21 years old
your looks alone cannot get you
everywhere for the rest of your life
she can now laugh and say i'm 40 and i
still look good and i'm still making my
billions and what do you got to say
about that she's like the
she wants to be in the level of sofia
loren and
you know uh marilyn monroe and elizabeth
taylor type of a level she doesn't care
if she gets married eight times
she just wants to get to that kind of a
level so when you talk about the cars
the cars don't work long term they just
don't work long term they work
temporarily they do not work long term
you